there are many deities that appear in
Norse mythology that bar and his father
Odin there are none as recognizable as
Thor god of thunder now in recent years
with the rising popularity of Marvel
comics and movies Thor is a character
that has become a household name if I
ask someone to describe him to me it's
very likely that they would say Thor as
a calm braid blond well-mannered hero
but this at times couldn't be any
further from the truth the depictions of
Thor that we see in the Marvel Universe
are somewhat borrowed from classic Norse
and Germanic folklore but of course
changes had to be made because at times
Thor was indeed no hero that is unless
your idea of a hero is an angry ginger
man who pummeled and smashes anything
that annoys him with his hammer so I
guess we can start with Thor's physical
depiction throughout Germanic and Norse
folklore Thoris described her extremely
muscular physically the strongest of all
of the Norse deities his beard and hair
were in fact red which were reflections
of his fiery temper there are however a
few poems that mentioned Thor's hair
being fairer than gold which of course
led many to believe that his hair was in
fact blond but often the term fair in
Norse did not mean lighting color but
instead refer to something that was
beautiful so these poems could either
refer to thought hair being blonde or
they could just be an observation of how
magnificent Thor's hair actually was
Thor's name originated from a variety of
words meaning thunder Doudna in all
German and fauna in old Saxon his name
was also associated with the day of the
week Thursday when the Germanic people
adopted a calendar system cemented a
Roman calendar they replaced the names
of the Roman gods of their own the day
of Jupiter who was of course regarded as
the god of the sky and thunder soon
became towards dag meaning Thor's day
which is where the modern English for
Thursday comes from throughout the
recorded history of the Germanic people
Thor was always a heavily mentioned and
predominant deity but it wasn't until
the Viking Age that Thor reached his
height in popularity amongst a
scandinavian people who valued and
admired the courage strength and brute
force that Thor regularly displayed Thor
was seen as a God who was most commonly
associated of thunder strength and power
the oak tree and of course war now I'm
sure many of you already know that those
father is of
Odin but he's motherf uragan or euro and
she'll sometimes referred to is quite an
obscure figure she's never really
mentioned in too much detail and nearly
things that we know is that she was one
of the owner and possibly a
personification of the earth with Thor's
mother B in one of the owner or the
Giants to some of you and Odin B in half
yatin that will of course make a god of
thunder 3/4 yotan which is quite ironic
considering that Thor despised the yoke
nur and the feelings are more and mutual
as Thor was considered the greatest
Slayer of all of the opener continuously
protecting as God from their attempts of
invasion and sabotage we mentioned
earlier that Thor was the strongest and
the mightiest of all of the Norse
deities but how exactly was he so strong
and why was he feared by so many the
majority of Thor's power can be
attributed to three main objects the
first of which being a belt that he
wears
meagan yard with Megan meaning strength
or power and yard meaning belt it
literally translates to mean a belt of
power the second object is a pair of
iron gloves known as young grip here
mean an iron gauntlets oin grip which we
can assume makes Thor almost unstoppable
in hand-to-hand combat the final object
is one that I'm sure many of you'll be
familiar with Thor's hammer Mjolnir the
word my own ears sort of derived from
the germanic word mala nun meaning to
grind earned in the hammer the nicknames
the grinder or the crusher which is
exactly what you would expect Thor used
the hammer for the hammer itself was
created by the two dwarf and brothers
broke here and Sindri but the only
reason it was made in the first place
was down to Loki Loki being he's Misha
for self decided that one day he would
cut off the hair of the goddess if
Thor's wife as you can imagine when our
short tempered in German found out what
had happened he threatened to smash Loki
into pieces Thor however was eventually
calmed down by Loki when he promised to
travel as far tell him and how the
dwarves make safe a new-and-improved
head of hair whilst he was in Sparta
lyin Loki challenger brothers Brook Ian
Cindy to create objects final and those
already made by the sons of Ivaldi the
brothers accepted Loki's challenge and
set to work
but Loki transformed himself into a wasp
in his attempt to disrupt them he did
eventually sting one of the brothers in
the eye and that is one of the reasons
given to Thor's hammer having a short
handle when Loki returned with SIF new
head of hair
in order to appease the early furious
Thor he gave him Mjolnir and a god of
thunder took a liking to this hammer me
only could never be broken no matter how
hard Thor shocked with the hammer and
when it was thrown it would never miss
its target always returning to Thor's
hand along with all of these powerful
objects Thor also owned a pair of goats
tongue grease near the teeth Bearer and
tongue your steer the teeth grinder
these goats serve thought well not only
because they pulled his chariot but
because he would often slay and eat the
goats of sustenance only to resurrect in
the next morning with his hammer there
is a story where Thor once visited the
home of some peasant farmers while on
his travels he shared his goats meat of
them and one of the young children broke
one of the bones and sucked out the
marrow when the gods were resurrected
the next morning Thor noticed one of
them was lame and when he realized the
child was to blame he was furious
the peasants beg the God for forgiveness
and Thor did eventually decide that he
would not kill the child but instead
take both of their children as his
servants there were several gods and
beings that could be seen as a children
of Thor the most recognizable being Modi
and Magni whose names meant brave and
great these children however did not
belong to his wife's if but rather the
yotan young Saxon
if the God Allah was not the son of Thor
but he became somewhat adopted as he was
a son of SIF and an unnamed man the two
mortal children taken from the peasants
may have been seen as servants but they
were also adopted children raised by
Thor and his wife lastly was believed
that Thorin SIF may have had one
daughter named thrud whose name was
thought to mean confident and strong
traits that once again embodied her
father over the years Thor had many
encounters of the Ahtna one of the most
famous being a tale of whom Nia who was
regarded the mightiest of all of his
kind
one day while traveling Odin came across
from Nia and challenged him to a race
back to Asgard
arrey said that all father one but Odin
being a graceful victor invited hoon
into stayin as God and enjoy his
hospitality the more drunk Runa became
the more he boasted about how he was
greater than all of the gods
even telling Thor's wife that he wished
to take her back to Jotunheim the gods
eventually grew tired of his behavior
but as a guest of odin they allowed him
to continue that is until Thor appeared
who came very close to smashing the yurt
into pieces but Thor not wanting to kill
an unarmed
man instead accepted a doll from Caronia
once on the battlefield whom there were
enormous stone armor but even this was
not enough to protect him
a sloth swung his hammer so hard against
through his head that it shattered into
pieces a piece of this stone lodged
itself in Thor's face where would remain
until Ragnarok there is another
variation of this story with a giant
fell on top of Thor after being hit by
me owner thoroughness of the gods
attempted to lift from his body but
despite their best efforts they were
unable to do so
that is until thoughts on Magni came to
his father's aid lifting the giant
easily despite only being three days old
another story that involves a yota but
as for Thor dressing up as a woman is a
story known as a theft of Thor's hammer
one day Thor awoke and realized that his
trusty hammer was not by his side
immediately assuming that this must have
been the work of a trickster he
confronted Loki on this occasion Loki
was not the culprit and wanted to help
Thor so he obtained the feather of freya
granting him flight and allowing him to
travel to Jotunheim
when he arrived he spoke to the yotan
King through him who confessed that he
had stolen the hammer and that he would
only trade the hammer for Freya's hand
in marriage
upon returning to as God both Thor and
Loki asked freya for her assistance but
she refused to go anywhere near
Jotunheim with me on her mission the
gods feared that the audience could
attack at any time and held a meeting to
discuss how they would retrieve the
hammer the god heimdallr jester that
Thor dressed as a woman to disguise
himself as Freya of course at first
Thoreau ejected this notion for he was
the mighty God of Thunder with every
other option being exhausted Thor
eventually agreed and with Loki dressed
as his handmaiden the to journey to
Jotunheim when the Odin king saw thorne
his wedding dress he was eager to
proceed of the marriage ceremony and so
the feast began Thor was so hungry that
he ate an entire ox half a dozen fish
and an entire cake the other king was
impressed by his new Brides appetites
but also confused Loki and his guy who
explained the situation by claiming that
she had fasted for an entire week before
the wedding
once Loki and Thor paid the customary
bridal fee filum kept his end of the
bargain and gave his hammer to his new
bride Thor unable to resist removed his
disguise took his hammer and destroyed
everything and everyone that he could
get his hands on the owner may be faced
enemies of Thor
but there is one enemy that Thor
despised like no other the enormous
serpent Yurman gand
one of Loki's many children the two
hated each other so much so they were
destined to take each other's lives come
Ragnarok the hatred between the two
began during the story of hood god Loki
during this story Thor perform several
deeds the first of which been to lift
the Kings cat off the ground
Thor eventually fells this task but at
god Loki reveals that the cat was
actually human and Thor not taken too
kindly to losing resented of God Loki as
well as the world serpent Thorin human
gang would meet one more time before
Ragnarok this time Thor was out fishing
with the Jotunheim ear however what they
caught was no fish it was indeed a
yeoman gand seen the world serpent once
again face to face only angered Thor and
a battle between the two began a battle
at Thor looked like he would emerge
victorious from him a however had a
different idea
scared by how close the boat was to
tipping over he cut the fish in line and
returned the serpent to the bottom of
the ocean Thor so incensed by him his
actions allowing uum again to escape
then in some accounts he swung his
hammer so hard
the yotan flew overboard and was left to
drown this however wasn't the last
meeting between the two come ragnerok
the two faced each other once again in
their final battle this time Thor
managed to slay the serpent but the
wounds he sustained would eventually
lead to the goal of thunder also dying
his hamon would then be passed down to
his two sons Modi'in Magni / amongst the
gods who survived Ragnarok Thor is a God
that many people viewed as an example of
what a great warrior should be strong
brave and always willing to protect his
people now it's no secret that wisdom is
not something that was passed down to
Thor by his father and his lack of
wisdom coupled of his short temper
doesn't leave Thor into some precarious
situations
despite this force of the greatest
defender of Asgard with the other gods
and goddesses reliant on him to keep
them safe from the constant threat of
the odhner although he may not be the
funny and charming hero that we see
portrayed by Chris Hemsworth Thor is and
will always remain one of the greatest
heroes to feature in all myth and legend
with Thor being such a heavily mentioned
deity please feel free to share any
thoughts and stories a garden will grow
fond of me in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology in
fiction explained